hi this is preshtalwalker
your parents or grandparents may have
had milk delivered to their home
and this mathematical problem relates to
that custom
imagine a milkman carries a full 12
liter container of milk he needs to
deliver exactly six liters of milk to a
customer
but the customer only has eight and five
liter jugs
can he measure out exactly six liters
for the customer while taking six liters
for himself
he can obviously use all three
containers in order to get this
measurement
the story goes this problem was asked to
a school child in france around the late
1700s he was so interested in the
problem that he went on to pursue
mathematics
this child was named poisson and he's
made many contributions to statistics
so the question for you is can you
figure it out how can the milkman
measure exactly 6 liters and take home 6
liters for himself
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for the
solution
all right we have 12 liters of milk and
the other two containers have zero and
zero they start out with nothing
so we're going to pour this milk between
the containers and we're going to keep
track of how much milk is in each
container
first we'll pour 8 liters and fill up
the 8 liter container
so that leaves 4 liters in the 12 liter
container and we filled up the 8 liter
completely
we'll fill up the five liter container
so we now have the amounts of three and
five
we'll take that five liter amount and
put it back into the 12 liter container
so we have four plus five which makes
nine
we transfer the three liters from the
eight to the five liter jugs
we now fill up the eight liter container
from the 12 liter jug
so that leaves one liter of milk in the
12 liter jug and we have eight liters
filled in the 8 liter jug
we fill up the 5 liter container from
the 8 liter jug
and that leaves six liters for the
customer
the milkman can then take the five
liters pour back into his 12 liter
container and he is left with six
and so now we've measured it out the
milkman can take home the six liters of
milk and he's provided six liters
exactly six liters for the customer
did you figure it out
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon
you can catch me on social media at
preshtalwalker
you can check out my books i provided
descriptions in the video description